[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
هذه الصور من تل ابيب مباشره واحتجاجات
متصاعده بعد خطاب لبنيامينه ياغور اشعلتيه
خلافاته مع المعارضه
[موسيقى]
وهذه الصور من المسجد الاقصى ما بعد صلاه
التراويح هدوء يشوبه الحذر مع استمرار
المخاوف من تنفيذ اقتحامات اخرى من قبل
قوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين
ومن مكه المكرمه اجواء الحرم المكي في شهر
رمضان المبارك نتابع سويا هذه الصور
المباشره من هناك
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
نواب ووزراء حكومه نتنياهو يتصدرون مشهد
التصعيد بالضفه الغربيه ويقودون مسيره
لدعم الاستيطان في نابلس
الهلال الاحمر يؤكد اصابه اكثر من 200
فلسطيني بالتزامن مع المسيره وتاكيد اممي
على عدم شرعيه المستوطنات
سابقا مسؤوليه التدور المشهد الامني ويؤكد
مواصله اولويات ائتلاثه الحكومي
الصين تنهي مناورات مثيره للجدل تحاكي
تطويقا لتايوان وهجوما على اهداف فيها
تؤكد على ابقاء حاله التاهب القتالي ورصد
التحركات العسكريه الصينيه
وواشنطن تدعو بجين للتهدئه وتعزز وجودها
العسكري في بحر جنوب الصين
الوثائق الاستخباراتيه المسربه مزيد من
التداعيات والاسئله البنتاجون يؤكد ان ما
نشر من صور يمثل نموذجا لاحاطات سريه تقدم
لكبار القاده البيت الابيض يؤكد استمرار
التحقيق ويقول ان الاتصالات مستمره مع
الحلفاء بشانها على اعلى المستويات ودون
استبعاد دور روسي مصادر ترجح ان يكون
المسرب من داخل الولايات المتحده
في الحرب على اوكرانيا تقدم روسي في دونتس
مع اعلان السيطره على معظم مناطق باخموت
وعلى الرغم من الاقرار بصعوبه الوضع في
المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه تتهم موسكو
باتباع سياسه الارض المحروقه وبعد تضمن
الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه خططا ومعلومات
عسكريه حديث في كييف عن تغيير في
التحضيرات العسكريه لهجوم الربيع
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المشهد التصعدي الذي
يتصدره وزراء حكومه نتنياهو اخر فصوله
مسيره تمت بحمايه من كتيبه كامله من جيش
الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه
نتنياهو الذي يقود التحالف خرج بعد ساعات
بكلمه من وزاره الدفاع وفيها تحدث عن نجم
مستمر في التعامل مع كافه الجبهات تاثير
على تشكيل حرس وطني يقوده
ووعيد بشان جبهات جنوب لبنان وسوريا وقطاع
غزه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي الى اي
اتجاه تسير حكومه نتنياهو في ظل ازمتها
الداخليه المستمره جاءت النتائج كالتالي
60% راوا انها تسير نحو مزيد من التصعيد
بينما قال اربعون في المئه انها تتجه نحو
تراجع في التصيد هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
اذا قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامينه
ياهو انه لا يريد معركه واسعه وانه سيعمل
كل شيء لمنع حدوثها لكنه اضاف ان المعركه
ان وقعت فان اسرائيل ستستخدم كل قوتها
واعتبر نتنياهو ان اسرائيل تمر حاليا بما
سماه هجوما ارهابيا حيث يعتقد الاعداء ان
باستطاعتهم التغلب عليها من لبنان وسوريا
وغزه على حد وصفه واضاف ان اسرائيل تعيش
الان في ذروه المعركه مؤكدا العمل على
كافه الجبهه ضد ما سمى الارهاب
مواطنين اسرائيل امنكم مهمتنا العليا لا
نريد معركه واسعه ونحن نعمل كل ما يجب
لمنعها لكن اذا اضطررنا اليها فسيواجه
اعدائنا دوله اسرائيل وجيشها وقواتها
الامنيه بكل قوتها ومن يعتقد غير ذلك فان
التقديراته خاطئه
في ردود الفعل على خطابنا نتنياهو قالت
زعيمه حزب العمل ميراث
ان خطابنااهو مليء بالاكاذيب والتحريض من
رجل نجح في دفع اسرائيل نحو الهاويه في
ثلاثه اشهر ودعته للرحيل اما بني جيمس
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي السابق فقال ان من
يتباك لا يصلح ان يكون قائدا واعتبر
ليبرمان زعيم حزب اسرائيل بيتنا المعارض
ان بيان نتنياهو يثبت انه شخص غير مؤهل
لشغل منصب رئيس الوزراء
معنى من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد كيف بدانا تينياهو في هذا
الخطاب وما الذي استفز المعارضه حتى شنت
حمله
عليه مباشره بعد انتهاء خطابه
نتنياهو كما نتنياهو يلقي المسؤوليه على
غيره وهنا عما اسماؤه بالارهاب القى
بالمسؤوليه على المعارضه او على الحكومه
السابقه مع العلم ان الحكومه السابقه
برئاسه بنت ولبيد حكمت سنه وثلاثه اشهر
بينما هو على راس الحكم وفي دائره صنع
القرار لحوالي 30 عاما منها اكثر من 15
عاما رئيسا للوزراء فهو القى المسؤوليه
عليهم في محاوله تبرئه ساحته ولاقناع
الاسرائيليين وكانه جاء من اجل ترميم
الاضرار التي او الخراب الذي خلفته
الحكومه السابقه هذا اغضب
المعارضه بشكل قوي ثانيا هم يلاحظون ان
نتنياهو ليس لديه شيء هو الى حد ما بنظرهم
مفلس ولم يقدم شيئا وان كل هذا المؤتمر
الذي عقده كان هدفه من وراءه اولا التحريض
ضد المعارضه التحريض ضد الاجراء ضد
الاحتجاجات على قضيه الانقلاب كما يسمونه
يسميه المعارضون وايضا التحرير ضدهم
وتحميلهم مسؤوليه العنف او ما سماه
بالارهاب المتاجج في المنطقه ككل هذا من
ناحيه الموضوع الثاني الذي نتنياهو قد
يكون هو المركزي الذي اراد ان نتنياه ان
يعلنوه ويبدو انه مرغما لان الدوله
العميقه في اسرائيل واوساط حتى في اللكود
والمعارضه والولايات المتحده اجبرته عليه
وهو ان يعلن
باننت وزير الدفاع باقي على راس وظيفته
كوزينه للدفاع ولم يجرؤ على اصدار الكتاب
اقالته عندما اعلن انه يريد اقالته ولم
يجرؤ على الاعلان ايضا بانه سحب كتاب
الاقاله فابقى الموضوع بان جلنت وكانه لم
يقال وان الامور وضعها خلف ظهره وان هو
يعملان سويه الامر الثاني الذي لابد ان
يؤخذ بالحسبان هي مساله حديثه عن الدول
العربيه المحيطه سواء لبنان او سوريا او
الضفه الغربيه وحاول ان يبعث برساله تهديد
الى الجهات الفلسطينيه والعربيه والمقاومه
على كافه اشكالها في هذه المنطقه مع علمه
بانه لا يملك اكثر مما قام به حتى الان
طيب هذا الخطاب او بالاحرى هذا المؤتمر
الذي عقده نتنياهو جاء ايضا بعد المسيره
التي تقدمها وزراء ونواب متطرفون
هذه المسيره ايضا التي استفزت مشاعر
الفلسطينيين كيف بدا او بدات مقاربه
نتنياهو لما يجري في الداخل الفلسطيني من
ممارسات اسرائيليه
حكومه نتنياهو الحاليه هي حكومه مستوطنين
بالدرجه الاولى والتي يتحكم بقراراتها
وتحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه بالزعامه
وهؤلاء مستوطنان مغاليان بعنصريتهما لذلك
مساله هذه المسيره المسيره اذا ما قيمت
بشكل دقيق هي مسيره فاشله لان عدد
المشاركين فيها والمبالغ به لم يتجاوز 17
الفا حسب تعبيرهم في حين ان هناك 400 الف
مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه وهناك من صوتوا
لليمين اكثر من مليونين ومئتي الف
اسرائيلي ولم يشارك سوى 17 الفا ومعهم
مجموعه سبعه وزراء ونحو 30 عضو الكنيست من
الاسرائيليون بالمزايدين لكن جميعهم من
المستوطنين لان الحكومه هذه حكومات
مستوطنين هي تحاول ان تنفذ هذا الضغط من
خلال ان تعطيهم يقوموا بمسيره الى بؤره
استيطانيه اصلا تعتبرها حتى الحكومه
السعوديه غير شرعيه وهي افاتار على جبل
صبيح في بيته فقضيه تتناول لا ترتبط
مباشره في المسيره المسيره لها حسابات
اخرى شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره احدثنا من رام الله
وفي رد فعل على خطاب نتنياهو فلسطينيا قال
الناطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم ان حديث
نتنياهو هو محاولات لقلب الحقائق
فالاحتلال هو اساس كل التوترات ويمارس
الارهاب واضاف ان تهديدات نتنياهو
للفلسطينيين وسوريا ولبنان وايران تؤكد ان
الكيان الصهيوني يشكل خطرا على كل المنطقه
ومصالحها
ومع استمرار التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه اصيب 216
فلسطينيه في مواجهات ببلده بيتا جنوب
نابلس تزامنت مع مسيره لالاف المستوطنين
يتقدمهم كما ذكرنا وزراء واعضاء كنيست من
اليمين الاسرائيلي باتجاه بؤره افيتار
الاستيطانيه المقامه على اراضي البلده
لم يكتفي المستوطنون باقتحام باحات المسجد
الاقصى خلال شهر رمضان المبارك اذ نظمت
جمعيات استيطانيه متطرفه مسيره شارك فيها
الاف صوبا بؤره افيتار الاستيطانيه جنوبيا
نابلس
المسيره التي اراد منظمها من الحكومه
شرعنه البؤره الاستيطانيه انطلقت من حاجز
زعتر العسكريه جنوب المدينه الى قمه جبل
صبيح بمشاركه وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه واعضاء في الكنيست وممثلين عن
جمعيات استيطانيه متطرفه
نحن لا نستسلم للارهاب لا في افيتار ولا
في تل ابيب من يستسلم للارهاب سيستسلم في
كل مكان لكن نحن هنا لنقول ان شعب اسرائيل
قوي ارى الاحتجاجات في تل ابيب تقول اننا
مضطرون لارسال جنود الى الضفه الغربيه
وتحديدا الان جميعهم يفهمون لماذا اصروا
على انشاء حرس وطني
جيش الاحتلال اغلق الطرق الرئيسيه والقرى
المحيطه ببؤره افيتار لحمايه المسيره
وتامين طريقها
الطريقه الوحيده للحفاظ على ارضنا هي
الوصول اليها بشكل مستمر وبشكل دائم
والتصدي اليهم بكل الامكانيات من الحجر
للوقوف للاحتجاجات للاعتصامات الموجوده
للمؤسسات الدوليه للمؤسسات الانسانيه انه
احنا مستمرين وقاعدين وصامدين في ارضنا
الفلسطينيه
الاف المستوطنين يسعون من خلال هذه
المسيره الى الضغط على حكومه نتنياهو من
اجل تسريع شرعنه هذه البؤره الاستيطانيه
وقمع اي هجمات فلسطينيه تهدد حياتهم
وامنهم
ففي مخيم العين وحي الجبل الشمالي بنابلس
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال شابين واعلنت عن
اصابه اثنين من جنودها برصاص مقاومين خلال
انسحابها من المخيم
اما في مخيم عقبه جبر فقد شيع الاهالي
الطفل محمد بلهان الذي سقط بالرصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال مواجهات اندلعت اثر عمليه
عسكريه خاطفه استهدفت اعتقال احد
المطلوبين في المخيم سمير ابو شمالي
الجزيره من قريه هيتما جنوبيه نابلس
فلسطين
في هذه الاثناء شدد ستيفان دوجاري
كالمتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
على ان موقف المنظمه الدوليه من الاستيطان
لم يتغير ودعا في احاطه صحفيه كل الاطراف
لعدم اتخاذ خطوات استفزازيه
موقفنا اذا مشروعيه المستوطنات لم يتغير
ونواصل الدعوه لضمان ان لا تتخذ اي خطوات
استفزازيه ولا يحدث شيء قد يؤدي لشعال
الوضع
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك دكتور مصطفى
الرساله التي اراد ارسالها
نتنياهو وحكومته من وراء هذه المسيره
مسيره المستوطنين والوزراء والنواب
المتطرفين
هذه المسيره تؤكد طبيعه الحكومه الفاشيه
الموجوده في اسرائيل الحكومه ليس فقط
متطرفه وعنصريه ومجرمه وانما ايضا حكومه
فاشيه بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه عندما يخرج
سبع وزراء من هذه الحكومه
وعشرين عضوا في الكنيست يعني حوالي خمس
الاعضاء اليهود في الكنيست لانه اذا
استثنينا النواب العرب يعني الذي حدث انه
عشرين من 110 هذا يعني ان المنظومه
الصهيونيه بكاملها تتجه نحو الفاشيه وان
هذه الحكومه تريد ان تكرس الاستيطان
وضم الضفه الغربيه كسياسه معلنه لها ولكن
ايضا هذه المسيرات تعبر عن الضعف في هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وتعبر عن الفشل الذي
يعيش فيه نتنياهو الذي اعتقد انه ظهر
اليوم كفاشل وضعيف وبسبب فشله في وقف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الباسله هو يحاول ان
يلقي باللوم على الاخرين ويحاول ان يستعين
باكاذيب
بالادعاء ان اسرائيل تتعرض لهجمه ارهابيه
وهو صانع الارهاب بنفسه لماذا بدا ضد
الفلسطينيين لماذا قتل والتنكيل لماذا
لماذا اعتبرت انه بدا في هذا الكلام او في
هذا الخطاب اليوم بانه فاشل في حين انه
مستمر بممارسته ولم يتراجع رغم كل الضغوط
اكان داخليه او خارجيه يعني حتى هذه
المسيره اثبتت ان حكومته ماضيه في سياستها
على رغم كل هذه الضغوط حتى الشعبيه
الداخليه لاسرائيليه
نعم ولكن هو يقول انه يريد ان يوفر الامن
للاسرائيليين هل وفر لهم الامن بالعكس
الامور تتفاقم وفتحت عليها اربع جبهات مش
جبهه واحده وربما خمس جبهات وهو لا يستطيع
ان يوقفها وتهديداته لا تخيف احدا لا تخيف
الفلسطينيين المصرين على مواصله الكفاح
والنضال والمقاومه ولا تخيف الدول التي
وجه تهديداتهم لها بالعكس هذه التهديدات
الفارغه التي اطلقها تظهر ضعفه وتظهر
ومحاولته الادعاء بان الوضع الذي يعيشه
اليوم هو نتيجه سياسه الحكومه السابقه هو
هروب من المسؤوليه هذا هو المضمون الحقيقي
لما قاله لذلك تهديداته لا تخيف احدا
ودعني اقول ايضا امر مهم انه لجا للكذب
ويواصل سياسه الكذب انما طبعا هذه حكومه
فاشيه عنصريه ولكن سياستها تقود الى
سقوطها في نهايه المطر وهذه النقطه تحديدا
ما اود ان اسالك عنها تقول بان هذه
السياسه ستقود الى سقوط هذه الحكومه هل
يتبلور شيء في الداخل الاسرائيلي
يشي بمستقبل قريب لسقوط هذه الحكومه بما
يضمن
بقائنا ياهو ربما بعيدا عن مغسله القضاء
كل ما يهمنا تنياهو ان يبقى في الحكم حتى
لا يذهب الى السجن عليها اربع قضايا فساد
وهو يريد ان ينقذ نفسه منها ولا يوجد له
سبيل اليوم الا ان محاوله البقاء في الحكم
لانه دليل الخطر على هذه الحكومه انه في
استطلاعات الراي الاخيره التي جرت في
اسرائيل
حزب الليكود الذي يتصدى تصدر الانتخابات
الاخيره هو الان في الموقع الثالث يعني
حزبان تقدم عليه هو ائتلاف نتنياهو الفاشي
سيخسر الانتخابات لو جرت لكن انا الذي
اقوله ان الحركه الصهيونيه برمتها المؤسسه
الصهيونيه تخشى كثيرا مما جرى تخشى كثيرا
بسبب انكشاف الطابع العنصري الاجرامي لها
وان الفاشيه عرتها بشكل كامل ولذلك ربما
هي الان تفكر بكل الوسائل للتخلص منه وهذا
يفسر شده وحده ردود افعال المعارضه
الاسرائيليه على خطاب نتنياهو لم يكد
بكلامه حتى خرجت مظاهرات ضده ولم يكد ينهي
كلامه حتى خرجت كل الاحزاب تهاجمه اذا هو
في حاله مضادعه هو في حاله فشل هو في حاله
ضعف ولكن هذا لا يعني انه سيقلل من
عدوانيته بالعكس نحن اليوم فقدنا طفل
الطفل الثامن عشر الذي يغتاله جيش
الاحتلال 15 عاما محمد بلهان عدد الشهداء
وصل الى 99 وهذا اعلى رقم منذ عام 2005
شكرا لك مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
هذا هو يصنف القانون الدولي جميع
المستوطنات المقامه على اراضي محتله
مستوطنات غير شرعيه لكن في التعريف
الاسرائيلي تعتبر البؤر غير المرخصه فقط
في الضفه الغربيه بؤرا غير شرعيه وقامت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه منذ منتصف
تسعينيات القرن الماضي بشرعنه العشرات
منها ويضغط وزراء اليمين المتطرف في
الحكومه الحاليه للدفع لشرعنه المزيد منها
التفاصيل في التقرير التادي
بؤره افيتار الاستيطانيه جنوبيه نابلس هي
العنوان الاحدث الذي يستخدمه اليمين
الاسرائيلي الديني المتطرف في جهوده
الراميه الى شرعنه المزيد من البؤر
الاستيطانيه المقامه على اراضي فلسطين
في القانون الدولي جميع المستوطنات التي
تقام على اراضي محتله غير شرعيه لكن في
المفهوم الاسرائيلي البؤر الاستيطانيه غير
الشرعيه تعني اي تجمع استيطاني يشيد في
الضفه الغربيه دون قرار رسمي او موافقه من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ودون تخصيص اي ارض او
تحديد حدود بلديه قد يكون التجمع عباره عن
خيمه ينصبها مستوطن او منشاه متنقله يتم
وضعها على ارض فلسطينيه بعد ان يستولي
المستوطنون عليها وعاده ما تشكل هذه البؤر
اما توسعه لمستوطنه قائمه او اساسا لبناء
مستوطنه جديده
لا تتوفر ارقام دقيقه عن البؤر
الاستيطانيه لكن صورا جويه ما بين عامي 97
و21
تشير الى تاسيس
243 بؤره استيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه
وقد انتشرت هذه البؤر في محافظات الضفه
الغربيه دون استثناء لكن العدد الاكبر
يتركز في رام الله والبير ونابلس والخليل
حيث ينتشر على اراضيها مجتمعه حوالي 64 في
المئه من البؤر وتشير التقديرات الى وجود
قرابه
من البؤر الاستيطانيه ماهوله اي
83% من البؤر الاستيطانيه بينما تحولت 81
من هذه البؤر او هي قيد التحول الى احياء
تابعه لمستوطنات قائمه او مستوطنات مستقله
المقرر الاممي السابق لحقوق الانسان في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك سيد جون كيف
تقيم موقف حكومه نتنياهو من شرعنه البؤر
الاستيطانيه التي هي غير شرعيه بالمفهوم
الدولي مفهوم القانون الدولي ومقامه على
ارض محتله
لا شك في ان بناء المستوطنات هو امر غير
قانوني
والوضع الحالي وضع خطير للغايه للسيد
نتنياهو لان مشكله عدم شرعيه هذه
المستوطنات الان هي معروضه امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه والتي تنظر في هل ان
اسرائيل ارتكبت
جريمه وفقا للقانون الدولي كجريمه حرب
لبناءه مثل هذا المستوطنات على اراضي
فلسطينيه محتله من المشكلات والصعوبات
التي تواجه المدعي العام في المحكمه هو
عدم توفر ادله كافيه تثبت ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في ضلوعها في بناء المستطاعات
لكن الان لدينا ادله على ذلك لان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ومن خلال ما رايناه اليوم من
ان سبعه من الوزراء الاسرائيليين بما فيه
الماليه ووزير الامن القومي ايضا هم كانوا
من بين الذين شاركوا في مسيرات لشرعنه هذه
البؤر الاستيطانيه اذا هذا يعد الدليل
الدامغا في نظري المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ونامل من المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه السيد كريم خان ان يتحلى بالشجاعه
الان ليبدا بعمليه توجيه تهم لاسرائيل
بسبب بناءها لهذه المستوطنات على مدى
العامين الماضيين كان هناك احباط شديد لان
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لم تقم بتوجيه
التهم بسبب هذه المستوطنات وكان هذا نتيجه
لضغط من الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده واسرائيل الان الامر بات واضحا
تماما من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
منخرطه في عمليه اقامه مستوطنات غير شرعيه
وسيكون
عفوا
عذرا عذرا سيدي جون عندما تدعو عفوا عندما
تدعو المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بتوجيه تهم وتقول ان الامر اصبح
واضحا بوجود سبعه وزراء ونواب في هذه
المسيره طيب توجيه تهم لمن بالتحديد
للحكومه الاسرائيليه مجتمعه ام لرئيسها ام
للوزراء
والنواب الذين شاركوا في هذه المسيره
هذه الان وبعد ان اصبح بامكانه المدعي
العام ان يبدا بقضيه ضد رئيس الوزراء نفسه
والوزراء المعنيون ايضا وواضح ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه نفسها الان منخرطه في دعم
الاستيطان غير المشروع
جندو جارد المقرر الاماميه السابق لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه احدثتنا من
لهاي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اختتمت الصين مناورات حركت على مدار ثلاثه
ايام تطويق تايوان وضرب اهداف فيها
المناورات ترافقت مع تحذير صيني متكرر من
اي شكل من اشكال الانفصال المؤدي الى
استقلال تايوان وعلى الرغم من انتهاء
المناورات الا ان اعلنت استمرار حاله
التاهب فيها فيما ارسلت واشنطن المدمره
ميليوس الى بحر جنوب الصين في تحرك
اعتبر ردا على المناورات
ليست حربا حقيقيه حتى الان لكنها حتما
صراع الجبابره في بحر جنوب الصين انتهت
المناوره العسكريه الصينيه التي تحاكي
تطويق جزيره تايوان اما تبادل الرسائل
الملغمه بين بيجين ووعشنتن فمستمر ولا سقف
زمنيا له
اختتمت بنجاح التدريبات التي حملت اسم
السيف المشترك وفق ما اعلنت بيجين وقالت
قياده الجيش انها اختبرت بشكل كامل قدرات
القتال المشتركه المتكامله لفروع عسكريه
متعدده في ظروف قتاليه فعليه بقلق وغضب
وعدم ارتياح تابع والجيران والحلفاء ما
جرى الاستعراض العسكري الصيني كان لافتا
جدا وهدفه تحذير اخر للراغبين والداعمين
لانفصال تايوان وهي تحاكي ذلك السيناريو
طوقت القوات الصينيه بالكامل الجزيره
واحكمت سيطرتها عليها تضمنت التمرينات
نشره مدمرات وفرقطات وزوارقه وقذفات
صواريخ تحاكي هجوما من السواحل الصينيه
على مناطق غرب تايوان باسلحه دقيقه شمل
العرض طائره الانذار المبكر والاستطلاع
وطائرات مقاتله الى جانب التشويش
العيون كانت ايضا على حامله الطائرات
الصينيه
محليه الصنع تشارك لاول مره في مناورات
عسكريه وضعت في الخدمه رسميا عام 2019
ومره اخرى حذرت بيجي من اي محاوله لفصل
الجزيره عن الصين الموحده
استقلال تايوان والسلام في مضيق تايوان
نقيضان اذا اردنا حمايه السلام والاستقرار
في المضيق علينا ان نعارض بحزم اي شكل من
اشكال الانفصال المؤدي الى استقلال تايوان
التدريبات التي اثارت حفيظه واشنطن
والاتحاد الاوروبي جاءت بعض اللقاء الذي
وصف بالمستفز وجمع الاربعاء الماضي في
كاليفورنيا بين رئيسه تايوان
ورئيسي مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن مسلسل
الرد على الاستفزاز باستفزاز اخر يبدو انه
سيكون طويلا واحدى حلقاته ارسال المدمر
الامريكيه ميليوس الى بحر جنوب الصين في
هذا التوقيت بالذات تحمل المدمره صواريخ
موجهه ومياه جنوب الصين متنازع عليها بين
بيجين وجيرانها ورد في بيان البحريه
الامريكيه ان حريه الملاحه احترمت وكذلك
الحريات والاستخدام القانوني للبحار وان
السفينه مرت بالقرب من جزر سبراتلي
المواجهه المباشره المؤجله بين بيجين
واشنطن يسبقها استعراض متبادل للقوه في
بحر تطالب بيجين بسيادتها عليه حتى اللحظه
ومن سواحل التايوان يتابع السكان والسياح
العرض بهدوء توقيت العاصفه لم يحن بعد
ويامل هؤلاء الا تاتي ابدا لانها لن تكون
رحيمه
معنى من لندن اليسيو بتلانو استاذ دراسات
الحرب المختصه بشؤون اسيا في جامعه كينجز
كوليدج لندن سيد بلتانو
هل تطورات الوضع
بشان تايوان ستبقى محصوره ضمن المناورات
والمناورات المضاده واستعراض القوه من
الجانبين الصيني من جهه والتايواني
والامريكي من جهه ثانيه فقط
في الحقيقه هناك امكانيه حقيقيه
للنشور بازمه خطيره وحقيقيه في منطقه مذاق
تايوان اذا ما نشبت ان تتسرب لتتجاوز
منطقه المضيق نفسه
لان تايوان تنتج مكونات اساسيه في الرقائق
الالكترونيه
المهمه جدا لقطاع الصناعات الالكترونيه في
العالم
والمرتبط بالازدهار في العالم اذا اي شيء
يعيق قدره اعيوان للمساهمه في اقتصاديات
دول كثيره سيصبحوا على الفور مشكله
دوليه كما ان هناك ايضا قضيه الحقوق الشعب
التايواني بان يكون قادرا على ان له كلمته
في صياغه مستقبله السياسي وهذان العاملان
يربطان قضيه واوضاع تايوان
باحوال المجتمع الدولي على نطاق واسع لكن
يعني حتى الان الولايات المتحده سمعنا قبل
قليل جون كيربي يتحدث عن التزام الولايات
المتحده بسياسه الصين واحده
وان لا مؤشرات في المقابل
لدى الصين على ما يبدو لغزو تايوان اذا ما
الذي يمكن ان يشعل ازمه او يشعل حرب مثلا
في في بحر جنوب الصين
هناك
نقطه مهمه عندما ذكرتم سياسه الصين
الواحده لاننا راينا من الان
مقاربه مختلفه من جانب الصين في تقريركم
اشارتم الى وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
وانتقاداتها
واشارتها الى مساله استقلال تايوان اما
اذا استمعتم الى كلام الرئيس ساي
لا نرى ان هناك
محاججه
تميل لصالح ان يكون كل من الصين وتايوان
تبحثان مستقبل مضيق تايوان على قدم
المساواه هذا هذه ليست خروجا ورفضا لسياسه
الصين الواحده لكن في الحقيقه تريد من
الصين ان الى مقاربتها من من السياسه الى
مبدا احترامه الصين
الواحده وكيف ان الصين الان تغيروا
سرديتها من خلال اعطائها اسباب مختلفه
للازمه في محاوله لشرعنه استخدام القوه
اذا كانت هناك محاوله تغيير الوضع الراهن
شرعنه عفوا سيد سيد اليسيو عذرا عذرا
شرعنه استخدام القوه يعني وكانك تتحدث عن
ان الصين تمهد لاستخدام القوه هل الظروف
تسمح للصين باستخدام القوه وربما غزو
تايوان وفي المقابل هل الظروف تسمح
للولايات المتحده اليوم بمواجهه تحت هذا
العنوان بمواجهه الصين عسكريا
السؤال ممتاز وسؤال صعب للغايه والسبب هو
ان استخدام القوه من الان تم تقديمه وعرضه
ليس من خلال نزاع مفتوح ولكن من خلال
ممارسه ضغوط ومحاولات اكراه
عسكريا صح التعبير لهذا السبب نرى ان قوات
عسكريه كبيره جدا يتم استعراضها في مضيق
تايوان طبعا
لماذا اذا لا ننظر الى الصين بان هذا مؤشر
من جانب الصين ربما اذا ردا على سؤالكم هل
نحن نتوجه صوب نزاع مسلح بالتاكيد هناك
خطر في ذلك وهل ستتدخل الوقت المتحده
اداره بايدن كانت واضحه بان اي محاوله من
جانب الصين لتغيير الوضع الراهن
عن التدخل الامريكان هذا السبب يجب ان
نعتبر ان كلا الطرفين جدا في موقفهما لكن
هل ستستطيع الولايات المتحده مواجهه هذا
التحدي
اعتقدوا ان رده الفعل في حاله ستكون
الدوليه ولا تقتصر على الولايات المتحده
ولكي تخلق الظروف المواطيه لايضاح هذه
الرساله هو محاوله الحيلول دون وقوع
الازمه اصلا شكرا لك
استاذ دراسات الحرب المختص بشؤون اسيا في
جامعه كينج كوليج لندن
[موسيقى]
الان مشاهدينا الى تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث حذرت القياده العسكريه
الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني من احتمال شن
روسيا هجوما صاروخيا واسعا على مقاطعه
اوديسا والمقاطعات الجنوبيه الاخرى مؤكده
ان القوات الروسيه تدفع بسفن اضافيه الى
البحر الاسود محمله بصواريخ من نوع كليبر
في الاثناء قال الجيش الاوكراني ان خسائر
الروس في بخمت تتزايد مما اضطرهم لاشراك
القوات المحموله جوا في الهجوم
مع تقدمها اكثر في عمق بخموت تحول القوه
الروسيه مكاسبها الى استعراض للقوه هذه
قوه فاغنر التي تقود الهجوم على المدينه
تبدو اكثر تصميما على اكمال المهمه وفي
الاثناء يجد قادتها متسعا من الوقت
لمكافاه مقاتلهم ومنحهم الاوسمه والنياشين
تعليقا على المعارك هناك قال حاكمولي
لروسيا ان اكثر من 75% من اراضي باخموت
باتت تحت السيطره القوات الروسيه وان
المعارك تدور حاليا غربي المدينه يقلل
الجيش الاوكراني من شان تلك التصريحات
لكنه في الان نفسه يقر بصعوبه الوضع في
بخموت خسائر الروس ضخمه والقوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل على تدمير مواردهم يقول
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بينما اتهم قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه روسيا باشراك
قوات محموله جوا
وتنفيذ ما سماها تكتيكات الارض المحروقه
بعد ان انهكت قوه فاغنر على حد قوله
مخاوف الاوكرانيين تتخطى ميدان بخموت فقد
حذرت القياده العسكريه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني من ان روسيا تدفع بالسفن اضافيه
الى البحر الاسود محمله بصواريخ كاليبر ما
يرجح في اعتقادها احتمال الشن هجوم صاروخي
واسع النطاق على مقاطعه اوديسا والمقاطعات
الجنوبيه الاخرى وبينما خافه الحديث عن
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بسبب التسريبات
في وزاره دفاع الامريكيه التي كشفت جوانب
من خطط الهجوم تتردد في كييف تقارير عن
تعديلات ومراجعات للخطط العسكريه واذ تشهد
معظم الجبهات تصعيدا عسكريا هذه الايام
فقد استاثرت مقاطعه خرسون بنصيب وافر من
ذلك التصعيد بلغ حد استخدام القوات
الروسيه قنابل موجهه على طول خط الجبهه
وفق المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
يستخدم الغزاه القنابل الموجهه على طول خط
الجبهه باكمله وبدات الطائرات الروسيه
باطلاق نحو 20 قنبله بوزن 500 كيلوغرام
يوميا والاعتراض تلك القنابل نحتاج الى
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات
وفي مقاطعه
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه سقوط قتلى
وجرحى في قصف روسيا على عده مناطق في
المقاطعه ورد الجيش الاوكراني باستهداف
مواقع التمركز الافراد والعتاد الروسي
واسقاط ست طائرات مسيره في المقابل لا
يتوقف القاده العسكريون الروس عن تصريحتهم
اليوميه بتكميد الخصم خسائر ثقيله في
الجنود والعتاد وتدمير منشاه عسكريه
واسقاط مسيرات لكن تلك التطورات على شدتها
لم تمنع الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني من
اجراء عمليه تبادل اخرى لاسرى الحرب شملت
100 جنديا من كل طرف
الحديث عن الوثائق المسربه في اوكرانيا ما
زال متفاعلا في واشنطن حيث قال المناسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان البيت
الابيض قليق بشان تسريب الوثائق السريه
واكد ان العمل حاليا يتركز على معرفه
كيفيه حدوث التسريب واضاف كيربي ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين تواصلوا مع الحلفاء
والشركاء بشان الوثائق وان وزاره العدل
تحتاج الى اجراء تحقيقات بشان كيفيه نشرها
ونطاق التسريب الزمني
هذا وقال كريسمار مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لشؤون العامه ان وزاره لا تزال
تحقق في حجم وكيفيه حصول تسريب الوثائق
السريه وان صور الوثائق المزعومه المنشوره
على الانترنت تبدو جزءا من كشف غير مصرح
به لمواد سريه وفي احاطه غير مصوره اعتبر
المسؤول الامريكي ان الوثائق
الاستخباراتيه المسربه نشرت بنفس الشكل
المستخدم لتقديم افادات لكبار القاده بشان
روسيا واوكرانيا لكنه اضاف ان بعض الصور
المنشوره ضمن الوثائق الاستخباراتيه
المسربه تم تعديلها على ما يبدو واكد انه
لن يخوض في صحه الوثائق المنشوره على
الانترنت لكنه اشار الى ان بعضها يبدو انه
يحتوي على مواد حساسه وسريه للغايه
تصريحه تاتي بعد ظهور تفاصيل جديده بشان
قضيه التسريب فقد ذكرت صحيفه
ان تداول هذه الوثائق بدا منذ شهر يناير
الماضي بين مجموعه محدوده العدد قبل ان
تنشر على نطاق واسع وتتعامل التحقيقات
بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين مع خيارات عده
ستستبعد ان يكون التسريب ناتجا عن اختراق
روسي
تكشف تفاصيل الجديده بشان الوثائق المسربه
ان كل شيء بدا منذ شهر يناير الماضي عبر
تطبيق ديسكورد وهي منصه للتواصل الاجتماعي
مصممه خصيصا لمجتمع العاب الفيديو في
مجموعه يزيد عددها على عشره بقليل بدا عضو
مجهول النشر ملفات وصف بعضها بالسري
للغايه تتضمن تفاصيل بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا ومعلومات عن اعتراض الولايات
المتحده اتصالات عاليه المستوى لدول حليفه
لها كاسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه الى جانب
تفاصيل عن الاختراق الامريكي للخطط
العسكريه الروسيه ما بين شهرين يناير
ومارس ظل تداول الوثائق المسربه محصورا
على هذه المجموعه الى ان عمد احد
المستخدمين الى اعاده نشر عشرات منها في
مجموعه اخرى تضم عددا اكبر من المستخدمين
وفق محللي استخبارات مستقلين فان من بين
الوثائق المسربه اكثر من 50 مستندا تصنف
في خانه السريه والسريه للغايه يعتقد
مسؤول الدفاع في الولايات المتحده انها
يمكن ان تكون اصليه اكثر المعلومات حساسيه
في هذه الوثائق تكشف اختراق الولايات
المتحده للحكومه الروسيه عبر عميل الروسي
شارك معلومات من داخل جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي ومداولات داخليه لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بشان توفير الذخيره
كما تفيد الوثائق بان واشنطن اعترضت
مناقشات دارت بين اعضاء مجلس الامن القومي
في كوريا الجنوبيه بشان بيع الذخيره التي
يمكن ان تصل الى اوكرانيا
واعترضت الولايات المتحده ايضا حسب
التسريبات محادثات بين قاده الموساد بشان
دعوه مواطنين اسرائيليين للاحتجاج على
تعديل نظام القضاء الذي تقترحه حكومه
نتنياهو الان وقد حدث ما حدث تجري
الولايات المتحده تحقيقاتها لمعرفه مصدر
التسريبات بدراسه عده احتمالات كان يكون
وراءها عميل لديه حق الوصول الى الوثائق
الرسميه المصنفه في خانه السريه للغايه او
احتمال حدوث اختراق لانظمه المخابرات
الامريكيه ومنذ احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر عام 2001 توسعت قائمه العملاء
الذين يحصلون على حق الوصول الى المعلومات
ذات اعلى درجات السريه ما يعني ان مئات من
موظفي الحكومه الامريكيه لديهم تصاريح
امنيه تتيح لهم الاطلاع على هذه الوثائق
تسرب الوثائق ليس بالفصل الجديد امريكيا
فخلال العقدين الماضيين كانت هناك العديد
من الهزات عام 2005 برزت ما تعرف بمذكره
داوننج ستريت وقد بدات القصه من بريطانيا
عندما سرب عضو في حكومه رئيس الوزراء
انذاك توني بلير احاطه سريه كان قد اعطيت
قبل ثمانيه اشهر من غزو الولايات المتحده
للعراق واشارت المذكره حينها الى ان البيت
الابيض قد تلاعب عمدا بالحقائق والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
الهزه الاكبر كانت بعد ذلك بعام والعنوان
الذي شغل العالم حينها ويكيليكس نشرت الاف
الوثائق السريه في جميع المجالات ومقاطع
فيديو عسكريه امريكيه من افغانستان
والعراق حينها ادينا الجندي الامريكي
السابق تشيلسي ماننج بتسريب الوثائق
في عام 2007 انتشر اسم اخر شاب متعاقد مع
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكيه يدعى ادوارد
سنودن يسلم سبعه الاف وثيقه سريه تناولت
العديد من برامج وكاله الامن القوميه
ابرزها عمليه تدعى برسمي كان من المفترض
ان تجمع معلومات شخصيه عن جميع المواطنين
الامريكيين ممن استخدموا فيسبوك وياهو
وافل في عام
عمليه تسريب اخرى تمت تحت اسم اوراق
الطائرات من دون طيار تضمنت وثائق عن
برنامج الطائرات من دون طيار للجيش
الامريكي وزعمت الوثائق ان 90% من ضربات
الطائرات الامريكيه من دون طيار لم تقتل
الاشخاص المستهدفين وكشف تحقيق لاحقا ان
المحلل الاستخباراتي دانيال كان هو مصدر
هذا التسريب
ويبقى السؤال الاهم في واشنطن الان مرتبطا
بهويه مصدر هذه التسريبات الاخيره
هنا تبرز بعض السيناريوهات التي تعمل
التحقيقات في ضوءها بسبب الخبراء فربما تم
تسريب الوثائق في الاغلب من قبل احد
العاملين بقطاع الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لتقويض جهود واشنطن الداعمه لاوكرانيا او
من شخص يحاول فتح ملفات الحكومه الامريكيه
خصوصا ما يتعلق بتجسس الاستخبارات على
حلفاء واشنطن الذين سبق ان تعهدت الحكومه
الامريكيه بوقف التجسس عليهم وقد تكون
ايضا التسريبات مضلله وتكون روسيا او
الصين وراءها وتكون جمعتها اجهزه التجسس
الخاصه بهما وسربتها لتقويض الجبهه
الموحده لحلف الناتو كما ان هناك فرضيه
وهي ان تكون التسريبات من قراصنه ليست
لديهم اهداف سياسيه معينه على اعتبار ان
كثيرا من هذه الوثائق ظهرت في الاصل في
منتديات دردشه العاب الفيديو
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع من واشنطن معنا
كريستوفر كوستا العضو السابق في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي سيد كوستا مرحبا بك
يعني بعد هذا الاستعراض اود ان اسال لماذا
عاده التسريبات تصدر من الولايات المتحده
اكثر من غيرها من الدول استخبارات او
بالاحرى تسريبات لمعلومات استخباراتيه
سريه تتصدرها دائما الولايات المتحده
لماذا
بكل تاكيد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قضيت بحصتها من التسريبات لا اعرف
بالمقارنه مع الدول الاخرى ولكن نحن دوله
ديمقراطيه وكل شخص في داخل المجتمع
الاستخباري يعرف
واجب حمايه المعلومات السريه ولكن بين
الفينه والاخرى كان لدينا معلومات بريه
سربت وبكل تاكيد هذه مشكله حقيقيه خصوصا
في الفتره الراهنه وبالنظر الى التاثيرات
على العمليات لهذه المعلومات المسربه
وبالتالي لن اجمل الموضوع نحن نتحدث عن
مشكله حقيقيه بالفعل نعم هذا يطرح سؤالا
عن سهوله التسريب وخصوصا انها ليست المره
الاولى يعني لماذا لا تكون هناك اجراءات
عندما حصلت تسريبات سابقه سابقه لا يتم
تشديد الاجراءات لمنع تكرارها وهو الامر
الذي لم يحصل
عنه بطريقه التاليه 35 عاما في الحكومه
الامريكيه اتعامل مع معلومات في غايه
الحساسيه يوم الاخير من خدمتي كان منذ
فتره وركزنا في خلال مسيرتنا على
التهديدات الداخليه في كل هذه المسيره
المهنيه وفي نهايه
المطاف يجب التوصل الى اليات
لحفاظ على المعلومات
وطبعا هناك اليات
لنشر المعلومات ولكن يمكن تخطي هذه
الاجراءات في حال قرر احدهم ان يسرق
المعلومات المصنفه واذا ما كان لديه قدره
على الوصول الى مكان لديه الدافع
بتوسيع هذه الشبكه نحن نتحدث عن تحديات
الامنيه مرتبطه بالاستخبارات المضاده يجب
تحديد هويه هؤلاء والتحقيق بشانهم ان
المرتكبين سوف يتم التعرف عليهم من خلال
جهود بين الوكالات ولكن الاف بي اي ووزاره
الدفاع سوف يعرفون من قام بذلك من قام
بذلك كان هذا هو السؤال التالي الذي
ساطرحه عليك طبعا انت لا تعرف الشخص ولكن
هناك فرضيات قدمنا مجموعه من الفرضيات ايه
فرضيه ترجح ان يكون مصدر هذا التسريب
نتيجه لخبرتك
يصعد في حقيقه الامر ان نحدد ذلك ولكن
يمكنني ان اقول انه في نهايه المطاف نحن
نتحدث عن
تسريبات مضره لانها معلومات مرتبطه
بالعمليات اعتقد ان المسرب يود ان يلحق
الضرر بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه بغض
النظر عن دافعه لانه ما من خير ياتي بعد
تسريب المعلومات الاستخباريه اذا ما كانت
صحيحه ونتحدث عن اكثر من 100 صفحه من
المعلومات السريه ما من شيء جيد ينجم عن
ذلك للولايات المتحده للحلفاء في اوكرانيا
في الميدان اتحدث عن حلفاء اوكرانيا وهذا
يؤذي جهود اوكرانيا هذا يؤذي جهود
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وشركاء
الولايات المتحده والجهه التي سربت تفهم
ذلك وبالتالي الغرض هو الحاق الضرر
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا ما هو
واضح هل لنا هل لك ان تشرح لنا باختصار
ماذا يعني ان هذه
الوثائق سربت
بنفس الشكل الذي يقدم
بالاحاطات
الامنيه لكبار القاده ما المقصود بذلك
بالنسبه الى السؤال نتحدث لم اسمع السؤال
بشكل واضح هل تقول المعلومات ان شكل هذه
الوثائق هي الوثائق التي هو نفس الشكل
عندما تقدم احاطات امنيه لكبار القاده
يعني الى هذا المستوى من الوضوح والخطوره
في في هذه الوثائق لكن ما المقصود ان هذه
الاحاطه هي نفسها التي تقدم لكبار القاده
كيف يكون شكل هذه الوثائق
هذا يعني ان هناك جهه لديها قدره على
الوصول لهذا النوع من الاحاطات
ولديها قدره على الوصول الى احاطات
هيئه الاركان على مستوى وزاره الدفاع
ونتحدث عن
موظفنا المدنيين ولان هذه المعلومات تظهر
في كل السجلات هذا امر خطر هذا امر حديث
وهذا يعني ان هناك جهه دخلت عمدا الى هذه
المعلومات هناك بعض التقارير التي لا
يمكنني ان اؤكد صحتها انني لم ارى الوثائق
ولكن هناك بعض الصور وفقا للمعلومات التي
اخذت عن هذه الوثائق هذا يعني ان جهم شخص
ما اخذتها من مكتب معين واخذتها الى
المنزل وهذا امر غير مقبول بتاتا نحن
نتحدث عن تهديد داخليا خطر يتعين علينا ان
نتعامل معه في مجال الاستخبارات المضاده
وعلى مستوى وزاره الدفاع هذه بالفعل مشكله
وهي غير مقبوله من المنظور الامني ولكنها
حصلت هذا يعني فقط نعم عذرا نعم هناك جهه
او
نعم هناك جهه او شخص قادر على الوصول الى
هذه المعلومات لكن ايضا هناك سؤال غريب ان
هذه الوثائق بدات تداولها كما يقال من
حزيران من يعني قبل حوالي عشره اشهر او
تسعه اشهر لماذا الان حتى اعلنت بهذا
الشكل وعرفت بهذا الشكل ولم ينتبه اليها
احد في السابق
اعتقد في حقيقه الامر ان الاوكرانيين
يتجهزون لعمليه الربيع التي تم الحديث
عنها واعتقدوا وكما سبق واسفت ان هذا يلحق
الضرر باوكرانيا وهو لمصلحه روسيا
وبالتالي التوقيت ياتي في سياق محاوله
تقويض
العمليه التي هي قيد الاعداد ضد روسيا هذا
منطقي نحن نتحدث عن موسم قتال اذا مسح
التعبير
شكرا جزيلا لك
العضو السابق في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي حدثنا من واشنطن
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل بكم الى نهايه الحصاد
لهذه الليله نشكر متابعتكم وتصبحون على
الف خير
[موسيقى]